it's a very positive signal from Jeremy
Hunt and Greg Clarke that they
prioritized medicines cooperation as
part of the brexit process it's really
important that when UK leaves the
European Union firstly patients don't
notice any difference so they can get
access to medicines quickly but also
from an investor point of view and for
the point of view of jobs here in the UK
we want to make sure that bracelet is a
success and the best chance of achieving
that is mittens cooperation so it's
really great that the UK government
recognized it it's a broad way for
ministers to carry on though by
publicizing their position via letter to
the Financial Times isn't it well I
think the the real issue here is that
it's important that everybody recognizes
how important it is not just for the UK
but also for patients in the European
Union that we sort out metals
cooperation as quickly as possible this
is in Europe's interest as well as it is
in the UK interests what we hope is that
the European Union colleagues will
recognize I think the leadership shown
in the letter today and start working
quickly to achieve the sort of
cooperation that's been outlined so how
deep is collaboration with the EU going
to have to go on drug approvals after
brexit what we hope is that much of the
cooperation that we see today between
the UK regulator the MHRA and the
European system will be will continue to
work and we understand that the role of
the ECJ for example the European Court
of Justice is a red line for government
but we think actually there are ways
around that we could envisage a system
where ultimately the UK courts could
have in effect oversee the last stage of
the process but the real work could
still be done in cooperation there's no
reason why that can't can't happen but
essentially you want a regime that has
equivalents with the European Medicines
Agency essentially yes and we want to
make sure that we continue to work
whether it's on the licensing of
medicines whether it's on monitoring of
patient safety of medicines which is
very important or whether it's on things
like infectious disease control across
Europe
you know this matters for people's
health so it's really important that we
recognise it quickly and we get it right
but because the UK market is going to be
smaller than the EU 27 post brexit
shouldn't we be doing things to make the
UK even more attractive a place to
develop drugs than it is presently well
of course the UK is part of a global
system of drug development we're a
global industry but the UK's are really
important home for the pharmaceutical
industry here we're thirty billion pound
contribution to GDP we have many
thousands of scientists working on
developing medicines many of the
medicines that you're I would take may
have been invented here in the UK and we
hope that that will continue and the
medicines cooperation the sort of
medicines cooperation that's been called
for today is a really important step in
ensuring we can continue to have a
thriving life science sector here into
the future but isn't there a danger that
if we do try and become more competitive
than say the EMA or even the FDA in the
United States standards maybe drop some
what would that put patients at risk
I think standards absolutely need to be
maintained nobody would call for a
lowering of regulation standards it's
there for a really good reason we want
to make sure that that's maintained and
we want to make sure that the UK
continues to work in very similar way
that it works today so there's
continuity so that there's certainty for
investors so whether you're a patient
whether you're an investor or whether
you're a scientist working in a
pharmaceutical company here in the UK
you won't notice the difference and we
hope that will be a positive step